η γερμανία που ήταν και ιοη μεγάλη μηχανεί παραγωγϊγής έχει εκτός από πολιτικά προβλήματα έχει
και οικονομικά προβλήματα ι ευρώποιι μπορώ να πω ότι η γενική οικονομία της ευρώπης είναι
ελαφρό χειρότερη όσουν αφορά τα επιτης εκατόν παρατην κυπριακή όμως η έλευση του τράμα βλέπω
να επηρεάζει την ευρωπή αντουλάχιστών κάνει αυτά τα οπία μας έχει πει πολλές φορές δασμούς
και ριπ αν τευθού δασμή του δέκα και ίκοσηνης εκατόν θα πληγούν φυσικά πολλές εξεβογικές
μονάδες τις ευρώπης ίσως όχι τόσο πολί τα γερμανικά αυτοκίνητα ιατί οι γερμανί έχουν ι
ηδυοτρία μεγάλα εργοστάσια στην αμερική αλλά αλλά ποροϊοδικα και φυσικά εγώ βλέπω ότι αν γίνει
αυτό το πράγμα θα επηρεάσει και την αμερική με κάποιο τροκοαρλητικό δεν είναι εύκολο πράγμαδασμί
καιόλα αυτά τα οποία ίσοσκεφτετιο τράμο γενικά είναι πολύ δύσκολο κανείς ναπει τώρα με τους
πολέμους οι οποίο οι οποίοαι ελπίζω να δευματιστούν επίζω οέο δοτολέι είναι αλάβει θα το
επαναλαμβάνει ναι ελπίζω να το κάνει ιγιατί και οπολεμον στην ευρώπη αλλά και στη μέση
ανατολή δυσκολεύει παραπολύ τ πράγματα πρέπει να πω ότι και εμείς